prix casimir pour le service bray dunes
on s'est tapé dans l'oeil du passant par
derrière il revient donc ça en écrasante
à l'alto la vie des talus bonjour joli
ça s'est bien passé votre entraînement
on va bien très bien je sais que casimir
fera très bientôt un joueur de tennis
tout à fait capable vraiment c'est vrai
quand on regarde un attention
ce match très bien attention coup droit
ah ouais attention mon revers
robert est un il se défend bien nos
formidables et bien tu sais le sport ça
nous allait des fins non ça m'a l'air
bon ce que tu es en train de délits soit
tu donnerais pas un autre pour moi ben
non je n'ai plus d'autres mais on peut
partager si tu veux tu en veux aussi que
dit oui je veux bien bon alors à temps
oulala c'est pas bien parfait ce que je
fais enfin prenez toujours ces deux
morceaux bon tu donnes le plus gros
morceau à casimir il a certainement plus
cinq mois merci ouais c'est vraiment
très gentil de tout partager avec moi
maintenant c'est naturel il faut
toujours tout partagé
[Musique]
quelque chose parce que ça leur on
dirait que mais oui mais oui c'est ça le
facteur et monsieur du snob sont en
train de se disputer est incroyable ça
vous êtes un personnage tuent pillent et
volent un peu minable et gaulliste pour
rogner nuque attaque la casta ou le père
et mes amis mes amis mes amis je vous en
prie que se passe-t-il
pardonnez-moi françois mais si cet
individu qui me fait sortir de mes gonds
chers amis je suis désolé de faire
assister à un échange de mots s'est vu
le gars est ce personnage ses bras
faites attention à ce que vous dites
n'est quartier jouent calmez vous et
dites moi si ce parent vous agissez
comme des bébés tous les deux sévriens
vente c'est vrai je reconnais que tout
cela est bien ridicule s'inscrit il est
évident qu un être d'exception
on se parle pour moi devrait pouvoir
maîtriser ses nerfs ben voilà vous êtes
calmer maintenant alors expliquez vous
gentiment
fait comme vous je comprenne quelque
chose mac malaisie facteurs alesi mais
tranquillement ou c'est simple comme
vous le savez nous sommes partis ce
matin monsieur 10,9 et moi à la pêche
pour tout allait bien le soleil
resplendit c'est là la mer était calme
bref le ton idéal pour une journée au
grand air nous avions décidé de déjeuner
sur place avec le produit de notre pêche
malheureusement quand l'heure du repas
est arrivé
bas nous n'avons pris qu'un seul point
son pardon je n'ai pris qu'un seul
poisson rouge je sais que c'était votre
poisson et voilà c'est ce qui a provoqué
notre dispute monsieur du snob n'a
jamais voulu que nous partagions son
poisson c'est normal puisque était
cantonnier condé manger sa cause sa
propre pièce aux côtés monsieur x non
vous exagérez un verrier dû partager
votre poisson avec le facteur pas mais
vous voyez monsieur du snop que j'avais
raison de vous traiter d'égoïstes
françoise mon avis ce que vous avez omis
de raconter c'est que vous y avez
apporté une bouteille de bon vin et que
vous n'avez pas voulu partager mes pas
me donner un verre quoi un pari vous ne
vouliez pas partager le poisson écoute
et il n est pas encore commencé
monsieur 19 vous avez mangé tout votre
poids son nom dans la dispute il est
retombé à la mer et vous facteurs vous
avez vu à vous tout seul une bouteille
de vin en entier nous les retombées sur
un rocher et puis elle s'est cassée on
savait juste à votre arrivée nous étions
en train de parler de l'intérêt qu'il ya
à partager la simu z'auriez duval du
poisson tous les deux c'est vrai vous
avez raison juillet c'est vrai sous
l'effet de la colère j'étais un peu
nerveux je manquais de quatre mois aussi
monsieur du scope je vous dois des
excuses
acceptez-vous de me serrer la main on a
mis au rebut bien volontiers oui eh ben
voilà tout est bien qui finit bien
pourquoi est-ce que voit que dans votre
colère vous avez oublié votre matériel
de pêche sur les rochers et qu'en ce
moment là marimoutou
mais c'est vrai vous avez raison julie
vanloo prévenez vos
combats je parle aussi mais je reviens
attendez moi
aurons
nous sommes arrivés juste à temps le
letton porter nos cannes à pêche rabat
chers amis nous devons une fière
chandelle
qu'est ce qui s'passe cabinet bondage y
compris que l'on avait tout partager
alors j'ai été chercher quelques uns de
mes plus beaux objets pour les partager
avec munich - l'artiste pour voir julie
j'aurais que donner la moitié de ce beau
des 5 mai casimir on peut pas partager à
10 mais si mais si on peut absolument pu
partager voilà bien pourquoi en soir je
te donne la moitié de ma plus jolies
poupées
monsieur
je vous donne un métier de mon téléphone
voilà
pour vous monsieur du snav j'ai quelque
chose de très beau voilà la moitié de ma
plus belle assiette
j'ai encore quelque chose
[Musique]
voilà voilà voilà il y en aura pour tout
le monde
[Musique]
brad richards j'ai dû écouter
heureusement que vous êtes venu ça ne
peut plus durer il faut que vous
président de la fête annuelle de l'île
aux enfants vous agissiez avec énergie
notre cher ami tout d'abord calmez vous
je n'ai pas eu l'honneur de vous saluer
ce que je déplore profondément bonjour
ma très chère amie excusez moi mais
c'est youtube d'abord calmer vos chers
amis rien ne put avoir une telle urgence
donnez moi votre bras nous allons faire
quelques pas ensemble vous voulez cela
me fera le plus grand bien justement
c'est impossible
vous n'êtes pas malade ou moins me
regarder seulement devant vous monsieur
du snad longue
mais qui a fait ça vous ne voulez pas
regarder au fond du jardin
celui ci est vraiment très beau
celui là aussi
splendide j'adore recevoir des dessins
écoutez nous allons essayer d'aller le
rejoindre oui mais alors faites bien
attention marché derrière moi
pourquoi fait-il ce l'algérie mais vous
savez que les enfants envoient beaucoup
des saints à kazimiyah repousse
attention j'en reçois aussi d'ailleurs
ah bon c'est étrangement jamais reçu
qu'un ou deux enfin passons alors il en
a reçu des centaines oui mais pourquoi
le positif sur le sol attention
attention votre post est bien parce que
les murs de sa chambre sont entièrement
tapissé et qu'il ne veut pas les maîtres
ni dans une malle ni dans une armoire
soit présent à chaque instant mais
pourquoi n'y at on pas dit que la pluie
pouvait les habits ni par exemple enfin
voyons messieurs du snop vous savez fort
bien que le climat magique de l'île aux
enfants fait qu'il y fait toujours beau
ah oui c'est vrai sus bête dans l'est le
tente on sait tous les jours le
printemps j'avais oublié
nous avons indiqué fermement que ne vous
inquiétez pas ne soyez pas trop sévère
quand même no no no no
casimir
aux messieurs du snarr vous êtes venus
voir mes dessins julie c'est vraiment
gentil de la voir annette vous savez ils
sont vraiment oui je ne
je sais vous allez moi vous me reprochez
nous ne pas vous montrer mes dessins et
de parler au nom non pas exactement nous
non j'étais venu avec le musée de lui
pour moi pour ça va je ne juge je ne
perds pas de temps vous les montre à
regarder celui là et d'un jean pierre au
merveilleux
c'est que pensez-vous de celui-ci en
fait c'est nathalie qu'il a fait quels
coloris telle émotion quelle finesse par
les merveilles la wii or ils sont
admirables kazimiya où ils sont très
très bon bateau laisse-moi les admirer
je les ai pas lues à casimir tu as un
véritablement de petites raideurs n'est
ce pas je serais vraiment malheureux de
les laisser dans un placard moi je dis
stop vous n'avez pas me demander au
moins de ramasser tous mes dessins je
serais trop triste eh bien eh bien voilà
ce qui ne peut pas durer ces murs
tu vas le cal trop petit pour afficher
des dessins aux six mois ne se disloque
en tant que président de la fête de les
enfants je décide la création du musée
que dean bravo monsieur dit content que
oui mais à une condition laquelle est
bien c'est qu'on vous est taillée au
milieu du musée d'un grand lit qui vous
tombe de façon que je puisse regarder
tous mes dessins semblent fatigués
d'accord année nous allons voir
l'emplacement du musée quasi niait tout
ce formidable tu viens joly non non je
reste pour ranger les chefs-d'oeuvre du
futur musée casimir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
[Musique]
beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
montrer
non
[Musique]
j'y vois des filles et les garçons
casimir choc cette chanson
france
nouveau jeu
mais je ne vais mieux pas si je raisonne
à fond
mais j'aimerais mieux peu si j'étais un
enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
laon le kiosque que les poupées
pamiers
couleur cerise
je ne
fillon
assis sur un pont
[Musique]
utile m
mais je m'en fais mieux pas si je devais
si j'étais à l'entente
à
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]